yeah I found as I get older that I do I
do have more of a selection and I don't
think that's so much a byproduct of me
just getting older obviously like I'm
trying to level up in other areas of my
life there's continual Improvement so I
get to a certain point I'll bask in the
glory I'll celebrate my accomplishments
for like you know a bit and then all of
a sudden it's like a loser again I'm
like I feel just I feel just as down and
downtrodden and motivated to step up to
the next level as I did when I was just
getting started years and years ago so I
think it's more of a byproduct of that
but I've also found that as you get
older and you put in the Reps that's
like when guys reach out for coaching
calls like oh you know what do I say to
women good example a guy asked for their
day is like oh what if a girl asks me if
I'm a trump supporter like well there's
three different responses if you're if
you're new to the game you know don't
talk about politics at all you don't
have the experience to go ahead and
manage and frame that conversation
um if you're an intermediate maybe do a
little neutral like oh yeah you know I
realize it's a polarizing topic you know
I'm kind of in the middle I really stay
out of that stuff I'm I'm on my own game
doing my own thing uh you know trying to
make my own dip the universe what have
you and then what I say is like not only
am I a trump supporter but I'm a
registered member of the party and I
said and I donate to the party and and
the girls like their jaws usually drop
but you have to have that experience to
get there so I find that I think it's a
byproduct of having more experience too
in the dating Market knowing how to deal
with these girls and then also you stop
you stop pedestalizing them when you
realize
I hate to say it but mostly we have this
conversation that the General's chat the
other day that a lot of women out there
are losers and when you realize that
you're the prize then you don't really
tolerate that kind of stuff I had a girl
over here the other day and she was I
went to the bathroom and I came out
she's on her phone like doing these
weird poses on this and this new couch I
had behind me like what are you doing
it's like oh I have to respond to like
my only fans guys I'm like all right let
me see these guys because I've dated
only fans Girls before and you know like
you can imagine what these guys are
gonna look like they're always [ __ ]
losers it's so hilarious but then it got
to the point like when it's time to go
to the bedroom she's like oh I'm kind of
I'm kind of tired you know I gave away
all my all my Sexual Energy I'm like you
just you just explained why you will
never lock down a guy like me and then
you know we banged and she was gone and
probably won't see her again because I'm
at the point where I want higher quality
of women in my life like she's hot and
all that stuff you know good on her she
makes she makes money doing that but
it's just there's a lot of women doing
only fans
uh there's a lot of women that try doing
it but I think the Market's saturated
most of the ones I've dated they don't
make a lot of money unless they already
have a following so there's a girl I was
dating here for a while she was on like
the Mexican equivalent to Survivor like
a reality show so I think she had like
300 400 000 followers already before she
did only fans and she makes pretty good
money but as we've talked in the group a
lot of women are irresponsible finances
so she was making about as much as I was
when I had one corporate client um when
I had like two or three or whatever
nowhere near it because you know like
Mexican income versus US incomes there's
just there's just a such a large
discrepancy but even she got to the
point making really good money based on
Mexican standards still asking me oh I
need some health in my rent oh I need
help with this I can't afford my car
payment I'm like what are you doing with
all this [ __ ] money like your guys
are paying for everything like where is
this going
whatever happened to the notion that um
you know Mexican uh culture is very
conservative uh
fathers are still you know respected
like we're the fathers of these hoes
doing only fans
yeah I think yeah like they have no
fathers dad's not in the picture that's
pretty much the way I see it and again
Mexico City is much more liberal than
the rest of Mexico so a lot of Mexico is
still really traditional but when you
get the girls doing this it's usually
they they come from broken homes uh you
know Dad's not around mom's kind of you
know the promiscuous side like you do
have that class of people and then you
put the internet in front of them and so
they're fun girls then yeah exactly yeah
I I tell girls here like there's there's
different categories you put girls in
like there's the there's the non-sexual
category that's like your mom your
sister your grandma female co-workers uh
anything that could get you in legal
trouble they go in that like just
non-sexual category your your buddy's
girlfriend your brother's girlfriend
whatever uh there's the fun girls which
like your only fan girls fall into and
then there's the girls that like you you
actually take seriously and sometimes
it's hard to put them in the right
category um you'll put you'll put a girl
in like a potential serious category and
then you know things will start coming
up you're like oh you're just a fun girl
and if you screw that up guys you're
gonna have a very very bad time let me
just um table this topic uh 50. did you
want to chime in on that yeah I I have
an extremely wide-ranging conversations
with with my girl and the other side of
taking the blue pill and ending up with
broken women is you know she's explained
to me the amount of loser men out there
you know guys that can't handle things
financially guys that are bigger issues
guys that have drink problems and it's
all because they took this blue pill
they got married they settled down they
cranked out the kids and then they have
to deal with the emotional mess out the
other side of it that leaves them in
their 40s and 50s as an absolute another
train wreck just like yeah that's you
know it's just there's two sides to the
coin of getting blue pilled and getting
plugged in you get messed up
um either end of it
um yeah
um I was going to table the notion of
loser women moth did you want to talk
about that a little bit I was just going
to chime in on jaren's comment about
like when chick asks if he's a trump
support like 99 of the time this stuff's
just [ __ ] tests yeah even got even guys
in a red pill they failed it he's like
well I'll just lie right now and then
maybe I'll you know and it's her just
trying to control you and say like yeah
whatever I am I had this I had a short
girl asked me recently uh and it's funny
because girls will throw a fit about it
and like oh I don't think I can see you
anymore all right that's cool and then
they're the ones hitting you up at two
in the morning like where are you what
are you doing uh I had the same thing
the girl asked me about sports the other
day like sports are huge where I am down
in Florida
um really successful football and hockey
team
um and it's like an obsession and so
she's like oh like do you like this you
like watching football yeah I think
sports are kind of gay like I think
grown men wearing like the jerseys of
other grown men like you know I don't
care about another dude's name I care
about my name and she kind of like had
this weird look and I was like yeah it's
kind of like that
um so you know most guys aren't willing
to admit that though and they can't and
they don't because they don't want to
lose that even if they're red pilled
guys like I still see it
um
but yeah that was I've said a comment on
that uh particular question yeah I was
just thinking about that actually you
know the whole like are you a trump
supporter I wouldn't even answer yes or
no I would just say I'm Pro mental point
of origin I'm pro-masculinity I'm
pro-family I'm Pro
um you know strong virtuous males having
competency skills and you know being
influential and socially competent like
those are the things that matter to me I
don't I think if you would just say I
don't care about like yeah man like
that's my guy like totally fine like if
you're kind of indifferent like you and
I are then it's like yeah whatever man
like I don't really get I don't I don't
sort of Saddle myself with other people
unless they you know sober to the point
of the whole sport thing like you know
wearing another man's name on your
jersey or sorry wearing another man's
name on your back or or on a jersey is
kind of a beta move like I did a video
about it a few months ago a lot of
people liked it some people hated it oh
I watch sports you're hurting my
feelings whatever I don't give a [ __ ]
you know it's like the whole thing like
why would you get like why would you
simp for another guy right like why
would you simp for an athlete why would
you simp for an actor why would you simp
for a politician like politicians are
[ __ ] I've I've yet to like I'm getting
old now right like I've yet to you know
be able to sit down and be like oh this
was a strong virtuous useful politician
like they're very few and far between
right it's all about popularity it's all
about like Trump trump had his Heyday
like he had his chance and in my opinion
he screwed it up you know like there was
a lot of things that he could have done
way better and I don't think that he
handled a lot of things well enough and
in some regards he was a bit of a [ __ ]
you know like there was things that like
the whole writing thing like I would
have squashed that early on like people
throwing Hissy Fits and burning down
cities like are you [ __ ] kidding me
like you let that happen in your own
country
but you claim to love your country like
you know which is it hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out